the advice I would give to educators who
are teaching this course would be to
first the class had a very technical
component in terms of the readings maybe
not it had a very one of the component
of the class was very focused on having
readings that really opened up the
discussions a lot of these were taken
from different sources different some
from theoretical linguistics to just
general readings from things like James
Baldwin or
open up ads from newspapers I think
having a strong I think having a lot of
reading material that can extract from
different places but that also is like
very good or that gives to a lot of
thinking I think that's something I'd
really hope was one of the best things I
like of this course
the second was is how this course is
also a place for dialog to examine
ourselves we all speak a language we all
have a sense of identity so thinking
about all these things with them from
our point of view or from our lives it's
very important so being able to have a
space of discussion a space in which
people can tell their own stories
probably for like most a good part of
the class I think that's one of the
essential parts to making this a truly
learning experience that helps you read
the word and read the world and not just
the word